let's say i'm 22. tell me what i need to
be doing right now to make every 22 to
30 year old that's listening to this
right now you have one major flaw i'm
generalizing you have lack of patience
elvis if you really want to talk about
it what people are making is they've got
college debts they've got their
ambitions one of the two let's say it's
a positive let's say it's a negative and
they pop out at 22 23 and they take jobs
that pay them four thousand dollars more
for something they don't want to do
because they lack patience
wow
uh-huh that's the punch line my friend
how old are you 52 almost are you blown
away as i am as a 40 year old man how
young you feel oh yeah if if i told 25
year old elvis at 52 you would feel like
this i feel better no no these are the
days and that's the punch line if if i
could wish anything right now i could i
would wish that everybody who's
listening that's under 30 could feel
what you and i feel right now i mean i
don't even feel like i've started